after watching scandal in West Wing and
[ __ ] you don't know what's going on so
there could be like a secret secret
secret service that we don't know about
I did really well in school I'm a good
test taker I'm really good at math and
science but I'm [ __ ] at history it's a
college prep English classes all
throughout high school very good writer
very strong of that good at history
horrible at math horrible at science I
got a perfect score on the AC T in
reading and did pretty well in science
but I did horrific in math I do like
logic puzzles I used to do them when I
was a kid and I do like to do the sunday
crossword puzzle I imagine to be a part
of the Secret Service you have to be
incredibly smart I don't think they put
the life of the president in just
anybody's hands the scary part is that
they like know a lot more information
than we know and they're always watching
I feel like this test is gonna be really
hard this practice test section contains
six passages each of which describe a
set of facts each passage is followed by
three test questions that are
conclusions based on the set of facts
presented in the passage you will read
the passage and then decide whether each
conclusion is true false or if there is
insufficient information to decide this
section contains 18 questions and you'll
have 30 minutes to complete it Melinda
is a Secret Service special agent Susan
has never been to Georgia all Secret
Service special agents have been to
Georgia
Fred works with Susan Susan is a Secret
Service special agent druvan is a Secret
Service special agent is false because
it says Susan has never been to Georgia
and all Secret Service special agents
have been to Georgia oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's totally yeah Fred works for
the Secret Service if Fred works with
Susan we know that Susan doesn't work
for the Secret Service
so then Fred wouldn't be able to work
for the Secret Service regardless of
whether
he's been to Georgia so he does not work
it's false insufficient information to
decide because I don't know if people in
the Secret Service work with people who
aren't in the Secret Service passage
three all Task Force agents work from
either Boston or Chicago some Boston
Task Force agents are financial fraud
investigators all Chicago Task Force
agents are financial fraud investigators
all Boston Task Force agents who are
financial fraud investigators receive
financial investigation training no
Chicago Task Force agents receive
financial investigation training all
Chicago Task Force agents receive
cybersecurity training
no task force agents who received cyber
security training are financial fraud
investigators how these broad statements
some oh that's the point
[ __ ] that be direct a life is about no
one in Chicago is a financial fraud
investigator
but we know that all Chicago Task Force
agents are financial fraud it so I'm
gonna say false it's sufficient
information to decide I'm just gonna go
all Chicago Task Force agents are
financial fraud investigators and all
Chicago Task Force agents received
cybersecurity training
therefore there are financial fraud
investigators who receive cybersecurity
training
therefore making the statement false
statement - no Task Force agents who
received financial investigation
training work from Chicago the people in
Boston get the financial investigation
training and the people in Chicago get a
cyber security training so it makes that
sure no one from Chicago receives
financial investigation training so it
is true I concur no Chicago Task Force
agents receive financial investigation
training I started to get nervous like
what if they moved
I wanted a perfect score but I
overthought it and died on the last one
so I don't feel bad that I did bad
because I mean maybe that means I should
like you know tap into that side of my
brain more maybe like this is like room
for improvement I mean it's [ __ ] but
it's room for improvement I just feel
like with these kind of tests you
constantly like second-guess yourself
and you don't really know so it might be
a test of like how much are you
confident with your like gut instinct
and I think a couple times it showed
that I wasn't it's not that hard to
figure out the answers and I got a 94
percent which is an ace I'm like you
know I'm pretty happy they should do
this test a while on the range and they
were saying targets popping up Fox
[Music]